one military spouse is hoping to inspire
change las vegas native vincent thomps
was selected as the spouse of the year
for the marine branch through a contest
put on by the armed forces insurance
network as joel muller shows us in a
story you'll only see here on eight he
is the first spouse of a same-sex
marriage to be selected for the branch
[Music]
me and my husband have been together for
15 years vincent edward toth's husband
steven toth is in the marines they are
stationed in okinawa japan this is the
military spouse of the year they have it
annually the las vegas native works with
a number of charitable organizations in
japan on and off the base because of
that work two friends nominated him for
the armed forces insurance military
spouse of the year and being you know
you know a latin you know young male
married in a same-sex marriage over here
it's it's a concerning opportunity right
now to do this he is the first spouse of
a same-sex marriage to win the marines
branch this is a huge message that you
that there are people that
survived on the don't ask don't tell
policy the defense of marriage act and
they are growing you know he's been in
for almost 18 years now and we did have
to go through that through his work with
military spouse organizations on base he
pushes for change i'm very advocating
for
inclusiveness diversity equity within
all of our volunteering there are
winners in each military branch and may
an overall winner is picked he hopes
this national recognition inspires
people inside the military and out i
hope that this message shows a lot of
people that
the community is changing
people's ideas are changing
and opinions are changing joe muller
live local now